[Music]
during the annual crab migration all of
Christmas Island is seeing red Christmas
island located in the Pacific Ocean near
Australia is known for its warm tropical
climate throughout most of the year it's
endemic red crabs can be found on the
rainforest floor but each year in late
October the adult crowds began a
spectacular mass migration from the
rainforest to the coast to breed and
release a into the sea this synchronised
breeding of about 40 million crabs takes
over the tiny island they take their
cues from a unique combination of
weather and the movement of the moon as
the rains of the monsoon wet season
return they begin their journey the
crabs arrive at the coast where they dig
burrows for mating
and then the females released their eggs
into the sea just as the high tide from
the new moon hits the shore these crabs
are so reliant on these seasonal cues
that if the wet season doesn't arrive on
time the crabs will not spawn until the
next lunar month they make their
migrations without much care for Road
rules or streams which results in
incredible and slightly startling waves
of red crabs moving across the island
[Music]